I can't believe that I can't believe
that Chris Parnell just wandered into
our studio and I never gave permission
for that no one told me you know is that
how we run things around here any
celebrity can wander in at any time
without my permission that's not very
professional I'm the host of this show
it's called Conan that's my name
I should control
[Applause]
it's what the hell is going on
you know Conan this is your show and
with the monsoon of respect I do not
want to step on your toes but I did find
partner will be charming tonight in a
gentleman it's very charming yes I you
gentleman always serve up such a nice
entree of comedy for the kids here every
show tonight how about some topless how
about an appetizer I just happen to have
the perfect top up for tonight which
would be a special look at the trailer
for my new movie the watch is a little
unusual for someone just walk in like
this and use my show to just play it
clip and as I said to you Chef Cohen him
with a typhoon of respect the last thing
I want to do is step on toes but I
thought I heard the growl from the
tummies from the audience and I thought
all right let's let's let's take a look
at this clip from the watch let's take a
look right now there is an alien
invasion happening there among us that's
why I found it the neighborhood watch
any one of these people to be an alien
check her out it's like she's studying
some new discovery should I put it in my
flavor snout I'm not gonna like when do
you be ground zero for some an alien
invasion we can't trust any look at his
face look at my face look at his face
and listen to me look at him and listen
to me look at me look at me look at him
and understand me look at both of us but
understand no one listened to my words
and here his face
I found something nobody touches this
ball till we figure out what it is
for the cow but this thing's awesome
anything from outer space you kill it
this thing's a goner for sure
[Applause]
that's terrific fitzy no next time you
can just call ahead and tell me you want
to come by you know
sometimes it's better to come
unannounced opens July 27th of Vince
Vaughn very nice to see you yeah
[Applause]